[свистить]
Я не знаю,
як працює класичний табір.
Я взагалі не уявляю, що це таке
і як воно функціонує.
Ми просто почали будувати
з нуля те, що ми хочемо.
У нас зомбі-апокаліпсис.
Знайте нас!
«Строкаті єноти» — це проєкт
таборів і пригод.
Ми не займаємось вихованням.
За десять днів нереально виховати когось.
Ми займаємось безпосередньо соціалізацією
дітей у середовищі собі рівних.
Строкатість — це різноманіття
досвіду, активностей,
щоб діти могли спробувати себе в цьому.
Підхід до дітей з позиції,
де можна бути максимально рівними
з дітьми і виходити з їхніх запитів.
Зачепив?
— Ні! Хіба палицею. Палицею.
— Зачепив раз!
Це було чотири!
Три!
Три?
Чотири!
П'ять!
Не попав!
Шість!
Це соціально орієнтована бізнес-ідея,
тобто ми займаємося з дітьми,
за яких платять батьки,
даємо знижки дітям учасників бойових дій,
приймаємо дітей загиблих
за символічний внесок
і не звертаємо уваги на походження
і соціальний статус дитини.
Усі рівні,
кожна зі своїм досвідом,
і всі мають шанс робити
те, що вони хочуть.
Так, відкриваємо очі!
Давайте разом!
— Я знаю, де лисиця!
— Лисиці нема.
Мені чотири.
Хитра лисиця, ти де?
Я тут!
[грають і галасують]
Коли мені пишуть:
[російською] «Вам потрібні вожаті в таборі?»,
без «добрий день», без нічого,
прилітає мені повідомлення,
я кажу: «Добрий день!
У нас немає такої посади як вожатий».
Це, у першу чергу, команда інструкторів
з крутим життєвим досвідом,
які прагнуть ним поділитися з дітьми.
Дітей багато, діти різні,
і для них потрібні
різні інструктори, різні активності,
і тому це люди з дуже різноманітних сфер.
Ті, хто мають супроводжувати рій,
щоб дитина знала,
що це та людина,
до якої можна звернутися.
Рої — це ж традиція,
яка йде, насправді, ще з УПА.
Група близько десяти людей
називалася роєм,
і вона перейшла в «Пласт».
І коли в нас говорять «загін» —
ми ж не худоба, щоб так називатись.
Що? О, це мені мушелька?
Здоров!
Мені діти привозять з плав мушлі,
я їх прошу.
У мене вже є ціла коробка з мушлями.
Так!
Ми встаємо о 7.30,
о 7.45 у нас руханка,
потім є півгодини, щоб привести
себе і свої спальні місця до ладу.
І після сніданку в них
ще є півгодинки-сорок хвилин,
щоб одягтися, зібратися, подуріти,
і тоді в нас перше заняття.
У нас є скеледром, мотузковий парк,
є смуга перешкод (з таких активних штук),
баскетбольний, футбольний,
волейбольний майданчики.
З таких розвиткових штук —
це «весела хімія» і заняття з мікроскопом,
і навіть вночі зорі в телескоп
можуть подивитися.
З творчих речей — це плетіння браслетів,
це для них дуже цінно.
Малювання, психогра — з психологом
дуже цінне заняття у форматі гри,
тому ми так його і назвали «психогра».
І, мабуть, ще щось...
Просто все не вкладається в голові.
Топ емоцій серед дітей —
це мотузковий парк, скеледром.
Дуже багато говорять:
«Я дуже боюсь».
У нас інструктор є,
він прикольно придумав.
Каже: «Ти не будеш лізти,
постій, подивись поки що».
Він стоїть, дивиться-дивиться.
Потім каже:
«Слухай, а одягни шолом!»
Цей одягнув шолом,
стоїть, дивиться,
але каже, що не буде лізти.
Він каже: «Ну візьми систему,
одягни, просто постій».
Той вже в системі стоїть, каже:
«Ну давайте я спробую хоча би просто раз».
І таких багато.
Толік для мене —
це дуже близький друг,
але він став другом саме тоді,
коли ми вже почали працювати разом.
Моє найправильніше управлінське
рішення цього сезону
було віддати повністю йому керівництво.
Щодня в нас є по три заняття,
щодня в нас є якась вечірня програма,
де діти більше тусять,
розважаються — якісь ватри, вечірки.
Якщо погода дозволяє,
то ми ходимо на річку,
купаємось, обливаємось водою.
Тобто вже такого плану...
У нас є така домовленість —
15 хвилин є обов'язковими.
Якщо тобі подобається заняття —
ти залишаєшся на ньому,
якщо не подобається —
ти можеш іти на регбі, футбол чи танці.
Сигнал зайти у воду —
це один раз я кричу, як павичок.
— Ви знаєте, що це таке?
— Так!
Сигнал вийти з води —
це я кричу, як павич, два рази.
— Питання?
— Нема!
[кричить, як павич]
[бавляться у воді]
[кричить двічі, як павич]
Виходимо!
Я займався активно
мандрівництвом,
був моряком до війни, на війні.
Після війни мені трапилось
тяжке поранення,
і реабілітацією для мене стала
мандрівка Сполученими Штатами.
Десять тисяч кілометрів
на велосипеді я проїхав.
Мене тоді вилікували
і підтримали люди.
Я шукав,
як я можу віддячити їм.
І коли я сплавлявся річкою Десна,
я зупинився біля села Кладьківка,
де були дитячі табори
мого дитинства.
Я згадав, як мені
там подобалось,
і я подумав: «От було би круто
запропонувати щось таке».
Але мені страшенно там
не вистачало активної програми.
Так склалося,
що я познайомився —
саме завдяки війні —
з власником цієї локації
Владиславом Кириченком.
І дівчата організували перших дітей —
це були діти загиблих, поранених,
і так це все почалось.
Основний посил був у тому,
щоб зберегти атмосферу
таборового життя,
наповнити її якісними заняттями,
якісним часопроведенням,
щоб діти чомусь навчились,
щось для себе взяли.
Це все — територія старого колгоспу,
яка перед тим була панським маєтком.
У форматі волонтерів
з'їжджаються люди,
і, на щастя, це команда, і дуже багато
батьків-учасників приїжджають,
і ми разом (от хто що може) робимо:
викладаємо, покращуємо цю локацію.
І це дуже цікавий об'єкт,
що стає ціннісно наповненим.
Зимові табори, по-перше,
менші набагато,
там приблизно 40 дітей.
І вони більш сімейного типу табори,
я б сказав:
Святий вечір, самé Різдво,
оці всі свята з традиціями.
О, це мені подобається!
Ми вийшли вже не лише як
літній і зимовий дитячий табір —
ми вже проводили цієї весни два невеличких
гірських погоди по 30-35 учасників,
один великий табір в Карпатах
на 90 учасників і восьмиденну експедицію.
Ми починали в Унежі,
сплавлялися до Хмелевої,
у Хмелевій сплавлялися до Устечка,
їздили в печери.
Раз! Раз!
Раз і два!
Хочеш — можна і більше: заночувати
і в наметах, і під відкритим небом.
Хочеш — можна займатися переважно
творчістю, жити в комфортних умовах,
чілити собі спокійно,
не напружуючись.
Хлопці, хто хоче позніматися,
можете зараз підійти до Ukraїner,
розказати кілька слів про себе.
Добрий день,
це «Строкаті Єноти»!
Так приходь, приходьте!
Це — табір «Строкаті Єноти».
Тут діти можуть знайти
неймовірних друзів та заняття.
Вони можуть навіть
змінити характер.
За табір проводиться кілька так званих
рефлексій або годин спілкування з ментором,
коли ми збираємо фідбек
[зворотний зв'язок] від дітей:
що їм сподобалось, а що ні,
які в них виникли труднощі,
можливо, хтось не може знайти друзів,
можливо, хтось не знає до кого
звернутися з того чи іншого питання.
Багато хто каже, що хочуть
повернутись ще раз, умовно кажучи:
«От я наступного разу приїду,
і я піду ще на скеледром.
Попрошуся і ще піду».
Головна цінність, якої мені
хотілося б, — це самодостатність.
Самодостатня дитина — тобто
самодостатній громадянин своєї країни.
І табір у цьому питанні
якраз є тим місцем,
де під наглядом дорослого дитина вчиться
самостійно вирішувати свої питання
і розвиватися у такий спосіб.
Ми як проєкт хочемо, щоб у дітей,
крім власного розвитку,
росло усвідомлення себе
як частини країни.
Ця країна в нас одна, це — Україна,
з відповідною мовою, культурою.
Не обмежуватися цим,
але завжди пам'ятати про це.
Для мене країна — це територіальне
об'єднання людей, які її населяють,
і чим краща буде якість людей,
тим краще буде якість
країни, території тощо.
Соціально орієнтований
бізнес для мене —
це ідеальна форма організації
людської праці і прагнень.
А якщо мета —
це соціальна цінність,
а діти і майбутнє —
і вона стоїть вище, ніж прибуток,
тоді все нормально, гармонійно,
і тоді буде прибуток.
Це, по-перше, тренд,
і це класно, що це тренд.
Головне, щоб це стало модно,
і щоб всі розуміли, що всі виграють.
Соціально орієнтований бізнес має частково
спрямовувати свій капітал на розвиток суспільства.
Ніяка держава не може краще стимулювати,
ніж бажання дати найкраще.
От якби всі працювали
від цього бажання,
було би набагато менше проблем,
мені здається.
На мене, але не говоріть!
Куди ще дивитись?
Замріть трошки!
[радіють і галасують]